en ce moment les candidats à la
présidentielle vont à la pêche à la
pêche aux signatures auprès des maires
il faut je vous rappelle 500 signatures
pour se présenter
c'est parti pour la course aux
parrainages la pêche aux 500 signatures
c'est une règle qui date de 1976 parmi
les 42 mille élus qui peuvent soutenir
un candidat les maires sont les plus
convoités
car ils sont les plus nombreux
comment les élus des zones rurales
vivent t-il cette course aux parrainages
et bien face aux convoitises des
prétendants à l'elysée plusieurs
stratégies en 1981 roger comme on décide
de soutenir un petit candidat ce qu'on a
coutume d'appeler les petits candidats
est absolument indispensable à la
démocratie
il exprime très souvent des idées qui
sont originales qui sont les idées de
l'avenir qui sont des idiots du futur
soutenir un petit candidat pour assurer
le débat démocratique ou autre stratégie
ne paraît les personnes pendant trente
ans entre 1965 et 1995 bernard suhard a
fait ce choix il ne manque ni d'humour
ni de persévérance monsieur le maire et
ce n'est pas faute d'être sollicité par
les candidats tous les jours depuis une
semaine il en reçoit des demandes de
parrainage de personnalités connues ou
moins connues mais à chaque fois l'issue
est la même c'est la poubelle
ce qui importe pour le candidat c'est
d'avoir les 500 signatures penser ça le
maire bd tant qu'il
bongo c'était ton ils n'en ont parlé de
rien à l'entendre les maires on s'en
préoccupe uniquement aux mots non des
parrainages preuve en est pendant cette
période ils croulent sous les demandes
les écologistes madame laguiller maigret
taubira jindam de les dom-tom je prends
les nuits yann millet nicolas c'est un
gars qui donnent des conseils en bourse
ça ce prêt seront aussi christine boutin
madela lalonde pour obtenir cette
signature qui vaut de l'or ils viennent
jusqu'au domicile il téléphone il re
téléphone élite ou même dans le
harcèlement des mères il ya des gens qui
vous appelle le soir à 9h30 il y en a
c'est le midi d'autres c'est le dimanche
samedi les pressions difficile à
supporter encore plus depuis 2010 est
cette année là la loire ont public les
parrainages avec la publication des
parrainages certains maires craignent de
braquer leur conseil municipal
dans cette commune le maire veut
parrainer un candidat de gauche mais la
plupart de ses adjoints vote à droite il
est donc très prudent si vraiment la
majorité de mes conseillers me disait de
ne pas me prononcer je ne prononcerai
pas sur un candidat pour éviter
justement d'avoir une tension après en
thaïlande prochaines municipales les
maires seront courtisés jusqu'au 4 mars
2022 date à laquelle les candidats
devront validez les 500 parrainages
auprès du conseil constitutionnel
[Musique]